we were getting new insight about racial
tension in America from Charlottesville
Virginia was exactly two years after
violent clashes between white
supremacist and counter protesters left
one person dead and dozens injured so we
brought together a diverse group of
people who were in Charlottesville that
weekend to have an open and honest
conversation about race
we asked ebrill Candi he's a professor
and founding director of the anti-racist
research and Policy Center at American
University in Washington DC to lead this
discussion in Charlottesville which
course has become him anyway is the
epicenter of our racial arguments in
this country arguments we've been having
really since the beginning of this
country in this room we have people from
different races people of different ages
people of different ideologies genders
I'm hoping we can have a constructive
conversation about race something many
Americans are just seemingly unable to
have and I think no matter your your
ideology I think most Americans would
agree we struggle to talk about this
issue in order for us to have a
constructive conversation we should
probably first talk about that that word
racist so let me ask you anyone raise
your hand if you consider yourself to be
a racist no one's raising a hand okay so
is everyone sure absolutely sure so how
would you define a racist I define a
racist by someone who thinks that their
race is more superior than or greater
than another race I agree with her
absolutely on that I would add one more
thing is that you use that as a weapon
in your actions it's not just thinking
that your race is better it's what
you're willing to do to ensure that the
rest of the world believes that your
race is better too and that somehow if
you're an other you're insignificant
racism is a system it's cyclical and I
think there are participants in that
system it's not just action
and you know weaponized actions it's
also in action it spreads out and
manifest itself in different ways when a
certain race or a certain individual of
a race begins to target and oppress
another sect of people just based on the
hue of their skin that's when it becomes
problematic are built right how the
systems were created we didn't create
them being african-american so therefore
to be racist you have to be on that side
in which you benefited from a system
that was built from someone that looks
like you but it's how the application of
those systems are because if justice is
truly blind then the skin colour isn't
supposed to matter I think it's the
attaching of a material variable to the
race itself good or bad does that mean
they came from a bad background does
that mean they're smart does that mean
they're more likely to be a criminal
right when you start attaching all these
other objective big words what people
call stereotypes yeah exactly but when
you when you put that into action that's
when you really get the systemic racism
from studying literally six hundred
years of racist I came to a definition
and that definition is someone who is
expressing a racist idea or supporting a
racist policy with their action or
inaction and a racist idea as I think
some of you said is is any idea that
suggests a racial group is better or
worse superior or inferior to another
and a racist policy is any policy that
yields racial inequity the opposite of a
racist is an anti-racist
if a racist idea is a suggestion of
racial hierarchy an anti-racist idea as
a suggestion and anybody wants a guess
of racial what equality equality and if
racist policies yield racial inequity
then anti racist policies yield racial
worth equity and when we actually look
at American policies we can essentially
assess whether that policy is creating
inequity or equity and we can assess
who's supporting those policies and
who's not who's challenging those
policies and I think what is absolutely
critical for us to have a conversation
about race is for us to have a common
definition of what a racist is I'd say
most white people are racist because
we've participated in the systems that
have oppressed people of color that's
patently racist in and of itself by
categorizing one whole group of people
we are all completely individual and as
long as we label each other your this
your that your the conservative talk
show host you're the politician you're
where we're making it easy on ourselves
so we don't have to engage and get to
know one another if we do not categorize
by race how do we see racial inequity
okay I think if we just try to stay away
from labels altogether and kind of be
colorblind what can happen maybe as like
a by-product is that we ignore the
inequity itself without those labels it
becomes difficult to actually take down
the system that is implementing those
labels in the first place like it's
ignoring the problem yeah and that's the
irony right about about this racial
issue is because in a way someone who's
anti-racist would prefer that if when
someone looked at them and they were
black or white or whatever they didn't
necessarily think a particular race but
at the same time we recognize that if we
do not categorize Americans in in
charlottesville by race we won't be able
to identify racial disparities in
charlottesville and if we can't identify
racial disparities in charlottesville
how are we going to identify racist
policies in Charlottesville and if we
can't identify racist policies in
Charlotte so how can we essentially
eliminate those disparities but when you
say we got a categorized by race in
order to break it you can
look at the variables that connect
people across races is it the poor
they're white poor people there are
Latina poor people there are black poor
people when you start unifying behind
other objective variables it's much
easier to bring people together to get
the numbers you need to enact change in
this country we have disparities by
gender
we have disparities by class we have
disparities by sexual orientation we
have disparities by region we have
disparities in almost every way
including race and what it seems like is
people are willing to acknowledge and
talk about and even band together based
on other disparities except race no one
wants to talk about about racism they'd
rather talk about race and and the truth
of the matter is this country was very
much founded on racist policies the
Constitution says all men are created
equal and yet they looked at blacks as
three-fifths of a person so unless we
are able to embrace and have that
conversation about about racism we can't
really have the difficult conversations
about the race let's talk about
Charlottesville is that okay I want to
model again how we can talk across the
country about racial issues because the
way to me we talk about racial issues is
we talk about racial inequities and the
way we talk about racial inequities is
we figure out why racial inequities
exist and so for instance here in
Charlottesville
black people are five times more likely
to be arrested than white people why is
that the case you need to ask the people
who wrote the laws that are being used
against them
the police chief doesn't just send
police officers out saying arrest people
is there a law that was broken you're
saying that black people are five times
more likely to break laws no I'm saying
that if a police officer or any law
enforcement wants to look at you you can
be found guilty of something going on
there have been so many laws written
the books that have built this waxy
build-up over our liberties that you can
be found guilty of anything any of us in
this room right now could be being black
in Charlottesville and growing up here I
can say that black people are likely to
be arrested more than white people here
because we're over policed so you're
saying that obviously if there's more
police in an area those police officers
are going to be more likely to arrest
people they're more likely to arrest
people then they're more likely to
incarcerate people as the law
enforcement and black person sitting
here policies are neutral
implementations of policies are not
neutral but as Tanisha correct in that
there are certain aspects of the
community where and this isn't just in
Charlottesville where there is a very
large policing presence that may also
result in over policing which are two
separate things as well when you have
other people or we have law enforcement
in a certain community you also have to
see is it driven by the 911 calls or is
it driven by the officers and the things
that they initiate so let me ask the
question in a different way when you
have a disparity between groups in this
country in this city there's only two
explanations either black people are
more likely to commit crimes and that's
why they're five times more likely to be
arrested or something else is going on
that is impacting this group and so
those are the only two explanations I
think that the cause of that is that the
systems were created by people in power
and so regardless were then I was
intentional those systems benefit them
and not other people or people in other
communities and as a result of that
we're seeing inequities and disparities
in order to talk about race and to talk
about what's a racist or what racism is
you need somebody that's been affected
by it in a way in the room to tell you
what racism is some of these people in
this room can't tell you what a racist
is they've never experienced it they
benefit from sis
that were created by their ancestors I'm
not asking any white person in this room
to not be a racist you can be as racist
as you want but I'm asking you to
dismantle the racist systems that were
built by your ancestors so that we all
can benefit so essentially you're you're
asking people to be anti-racist because
that's essentially he keeps saying
humanity and we all were talking we can
talk all day America been talking for
five hundred years seven hundred years
how many years you said earlier all
we've been doing is talking let's move
it forward why don't we move forward and
say it's like what can we as a diverse
community of Charlottesville do to move
ourselves together out of this situation
and I believe it's transparency of
information having talked about what a
policy means and how when it trickles
through the bureaucratic layers it gets
tainted we white people have bought into
this myth of meritocracy where you can
get ahead if you just work hard enough
and so we've all thought oh well we
worked hard we went to college we got a
good job that must be me but again it
goes back to it's not the individual
it's the systems that we've benefited
from that have allowed us to exceed race
for so long White's have started at the
40-yard line
right so they book just always had a
head start we still have to wrap our
heads around the fact that August 12th
happened in Charlottesville for a reason
that underbelly of racism that that was
running here before that fateful weekend
still very much exist here today I can
shed or I can hide or camouflage every
other variable about me my social
economic status I can do it about my
education my religious affiliations my
beliefs around my sexual orientation or
any of those I cannot walk out the door
ever and shed that I am a black woman
ever I don't get to just cover that up
so I represent a lot of undocumented
I have to tell them that they have to
live their life by a higher standard
than any other normal teenager who's
capable of making a stupid mistake I
have to tell them you don't have the
liberty to do that because it can mean
consequences for you
that are unfathomable to just your
average American kid I believe there are
a number of people who do not understand
what you just said and I believe that's
the growth point the transformation to
help people what can we do to grow the
number of white people who acknowledge
understand and are awake I think there
are certain people who just don't know
but I think we can't forget that we have
people actively producing ideas and mass
circulating them that there's something
wrong with Latinas immigrants there's
something wrong with so-called black
criminals I think it's critical for
people particularly white people to have
an awareness of white privilege I mean
just the phrase white privilege is
racist I barely make more than the
poverty level in Charlottesville all my
kids went to public school so thank you
white privilege is racist yeah what
privilege should my kids head I'm just
great well yeah let me ask you do you
think white poverty or black poverty is
more dense in this country so for
instance in Chicago a black poor person
it's ten times more likely to live in a
neighborhood with other poor black
people than a white poor person and so
what that means ultimately is even white
poor people benefit we're not poor
people live but they live among other
people who aren't they're more likely to
live among other people who are not poor
I would say that like white privilege
exists in like so maybe a person who is
white and poor does not have an economic
privilege but they might have privilege
in other ways like if I'm a cop who is
used to resting mostly black people I
come across you maybe your you're white
so I'm gonna be like okay like it's
probably fine I won't rail on this other
person like so even if you're not behind
in fitting Eck
there on other ways that whiteness can
benefit you we have so many disparities
in this town because when you look at
the power structure if we had an org
chart of Charlotte Hsu and you look at
all the people in positions of power
ninety percent are white if we're
talking about the building of two
hundred and fifty years of of systems
that had racist components changing the
the the race of the people at the top of
the system is not anti-racist this
system still intact so you can have a
black superintendent a black chief of
police a black mayor you can be
Baltimore right have several Chiefs of
Police several mayor's but the policies
in the system it's the government
quicken and we go right we've gotta stop
reading policy and actually start
writing policy the Lord teaches you that
faith without works is dead so we've got
to stop talking about these things that
actually put some muscle into meat
behind them and start doing them
precisely and that's why I like memory
and earlier I distinguish between a
racist and an anti-racist policy and you
know you need people in positions of
power to in order to enact and even
defend policies and so I think
fundamentally at our core right we're
having an argument over policy over
policies that create racial inequity and
then people because of their racist idea
saying Oh black people should be more
likely to be impoverished even though
it's stemming out of what the policies
and so you know I think that we should
be having that type of discussion which
is why I wanted us to talk about racial
disparities in this city right because
there was either an explanation of it
was because of racist policies or the
explanation was what there's something
wrong with black people which is a
racist ideas and that's the debate we're
having all over this country about race
we're having a debate between what is
the problem racist policy or racist
ideas and we need to recognize and we
need to recognize that we need
anti-racist policies some very
interesting points if only he can
explain that
wider group and in fact he did in a book
thing shortly oh and a wider okay de are
that would help a wider group with a DV
was saying but black please chief black
Mary could have a black president people
think okay we're done with race racial
problems in this country is we know that
just is not the case